kinds of filmmakers submit their films
to Sundance every year and and only a
couple hundred are accepted so if
someone came to you and said I want to
get my phone to Sundance what would you
tell them he says you know great fella
paperwork at the hundred dollar check or
whatever it is if it's is it finished or
they haven't made it yet because I would
have advised on both sides okay I think
it wasn't major what I would say then is
I feel like and I'm guessing here but I
do feel like I've gotten to know the
Sundance people over the years and when
I look at the films I do feel like
they're people argued nepotism a lot you
know they're like oh it's movies within
develop I've never personally seen that
you know I've never seen someone get in
just because in fact I've seen people
not get in that you would think that
they should because of what net because
of those nepotism things I don't think
that Trevor and Jon run it that way at
all I think they truly program off their
God and I mean every film festivals a
business so there's always that side to
it but you know that's why they have
premiere sections and stuff like that
but I think when you look at the
competition section I think they just
choose stuff that's it's bold I think
they're looking for something that's you
know has some kind of unique identity to
it that's what I would say to someone
like make sure your film has Urich don't
try to make a movie that you think would
fit the sundance mold you know make a
movie that is just of your own and I
think next is really epitomized that
then why forget some of the most
important I mean more most exciting
movies happening there in the next
category because they're just they're
usually really really unique identities
and I think that I mean I would say that
anyone independent of Sundance like just
make sure your movie reflects yourself
you know don't try to even even when it
comes up some music or the way it's
gonna look like don't don't try to make
it look that way because another movie
did it you know that's always my least
favorite question to answer someone will
be like what what other movie do you
think this movie will be like you know
before you make it and I'm like well I'm
not gonna it's gonna be the way I think
I'm gonna make it I'll have
illustrations to show that but I'm not
gonna compare it to it and I think
that's the most important thing and I
think when it comes to submissions I
think you've got to formalize it you've
got to do this a formal submission
process I don't think it you know are
thousands of films I don't think it
hurts not to pull strings but I don't
think if you have some kind of some way
just to make sure your to get your name
mentioned not to say that you should
show up I don't believe in you know that
kind of thing I don't think it need to
campaign
your film you know I think the film will
stand it's on on its own and they do
watch the movies and everything like
that but to inquire or nudge or ask a
friend to put in a good word or whatever
I do that all the time for my friends
with other film festivals I don't think
that necessarily guarantees you or gets
you in or anything like that but it
doesn't hurt to just for someone to
remember your name and have it be set I
mean that's advice I would say a totally
independent of something it's just for
anything in life nevertheless you know
to be bold and be persistent you know
those things that exist but I think also
the most important thing I think to
submit to Sundance is to not expect to
get in I don't that's not like it sounds
negative I just think in a positive way
I put too much on myself my firt when my
first film didn't get in it was like
rushing to me and it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be no no festival should
determine your worth that much you know
and I'm glad I had that experience of
not getting in you know it didn't I
I've learned to not let any festival be
the indicator of the quality of your
film you know only you should be the
indicator of that you know and so that's
I think what I would tell people first
and foremost but you know - I always say
don't expect it but plan on it you know
if you can shoot your film a little
sooner and have enough time to edit it
to get it in time like try to do it try
to try to do what you can to have it
there and it be placed in a position
where it could be accepted you know um
also trust that they are used to seeing
rough cuts they saw really rough cut of
my film and I was really uncomfortable
about it but they that's their job is to
see the see what the film is going to
become you know festival programmers see
rough versions of films all the time and
my initial on my first film I was like
it needs to be totally finished and it
needs to be sound mix and everything you
need to know there needs to be no room
for what they think but I realized that
it's it's actually okay like they're
they're really tuned to that to the
filmmaker process in the post-production
process and make sure you're submitting
something you can stand behind you know
that that to me feels like like if you
never get a chance to people play their
films at festivals sometimes I mean like
well it's still a work in progress and I
was like no way I need to like granted
of course you always want to make
changes to your film but I played it
played my film at the cut at Sundance
which it very little time to finish I
played that there with the assumption
I'll never get to touch again and
actually I probably won't but you know I
had to be okay with that where other
people I know that like well I'm still
think about doing this and tweaking this
and like you probably shouldn't be
charging people money to see your film
then that's just that's just my opinion
you know I mean everyone runs a
different way but in terms of getting in
that's I think it's a plan for it put
your best foot forward
you know submit it formally try to
inquire if you can if you know someone
who knows a programmer just you know say
hey put in a good word for me I I would
say just to do that just to create
awareness of the project but having said
that a night program for festivals
before not Sundance but I really i watch
everything every festival program I know
they do watch things there's always this
sort of angst about well they will they
really watch it or not and they will
because that I feel like the true
festival programmer you know when you
meet the people who've been doing it
their whole lives what they want they
want like I said when I read the script
the first time I want to like when they
put in a movie I think they always want
to love it they want to discover that
movie that like someone made in their
backyard in Tennessee that's like
unheard of and unparalleled and totally
unique and creative like that's what
their desire is for and so I think you
want you want to keep that in mind that
they're they're not sitting I rarely
seen a festival programmer that's a
cynic
you know where usually they have that
optimism of wanting to find something
great in the middle of thousands of
thousands of movies and most of those
thousands of movies aren't you know it's
strange you think like God who made 12
thousand movies you might think oh I
think a lot of times they're really
rough you know sometimes the movies are
really rough and maybe don't aren't
unique enough but you know it's I do
think everything does get considered
you